Херсон же у цьому особливий.
І, як запевняють художники,
цю родзинку, будь-що, варто зберегти.
Є таке чітке бачення Херсона
як великий, цікавий центр культури.
Чи це музей сучасного мистецтва,
який ми таки будемо будувати.
До студентського міста з музичними,
театральними фестивалями.
У нас середовище вже досить зріле для того,
щоб проводити такі заходи, як фести.
Тому Херсон бачу як молодіжне,
студентське, фестивальне місто.
Я сам херсонець.
Просто 30 років не жив у Херсоні.
Приїхав і познайомився з іншим
Херсоном, якого я не знав.
І це було дуже цікаво і перспективно
робити якось гуртом.
Щось таке, що ти не помічаєш
як колективну працю.
А тут рух,
тут ціла спільнота.
Зі своєю історією,
своїми школами.
Це було значно цікавіше,
ніж живопис на той період.
Тому й відсутність галерей у Херсоні...
Зараз у мене майно,
і тому я це майно вклав у мистецтво.
Створив галерею у хаті в себе.
Ти живеш всередині подій,
всередині картин.
І це дуже цікава позиція для митця.
Мабуть, цікавішою була
сама спільнота, люди, митці,
з якими я тут, у Херсоні,
познайомився.
Пишемо.
Це — народної художниці
Поліни Райко,
котра здивувала мистецький світ
своїм творінням,
яке відтворила в Олешках.
Для мене Поліна Райко —
це натхнення.
Це підтвердження того,
що може підтвердитися в долі митця.
Я відчув ту хвилю,
яка мені гармонійна, цікава.
І дуже продуктивна.
В якому ключі?
У тому, що це дійсно
витвір мистецтва.
З долею мистецтва,
типовою в багатьох випадках.
Тут ключова робота,
яку вона дуже відзначала і любила.
Ця робота називається
«Дорога до раю».
Вона почала малювати у 68-69 років.
За п'ять років створила
історію свого життя.
Історію в цих пейзажах,
котрі вона перенесла на стіни.
Там можна побачити
якусь рослинність.
Але їй чогось не вистачало,
і вона казала:
«Мені писати ні на чому».
Тому ми й вирішили
привезти їй полотна.
Коли привезли полотна,
я вже багато розповідав,
що ми буквально
на тиждень розминулися.
Вона як померла...
І ось будинок розмалювала і все,
проєкт закінчився.
Фонд саме тому взяв
на себе таку відповідальність:
придивлятися за будиночком,
щось робити...
І інтригувати суспільство на якісь дії.